des exercices comme le travail vocal
l'addiction l'interprétation ou encore
l'improvisation sont mises en pratique
au fil des ateliers dispensés sur le
parvis de l'undd théâtre centre d'art
deviez l'isi villacoublay
c'est pas forcément pour en faire un
métier mais si vous avez déjà une
certaine maturité et une sensibilité
aussi oui c'est sous construire les
ateliers sont gratuits sur inscription
avec une limite de neuf personnes par
atelier durant une heure et demie
pas besoin d'expérience de jeu il est
possible de venir pour découvrir ce
nouveau monde
j'avais déjà fait du théâtre quand
j'étais petit mais celui là on a promise
à sion je préfère la provocation parce
que j'aime bien imaginer à l'avancé
plutôt qu'à prendre un texte
certains n'en sont qu'à leurs premiers
tours d'essai d'autres sont des adeptes
de la comédie et la pratique
régulièrement
je suis venu parce que ma mère elle dit
que bah je fais beaucoup de théâtre ça
pas que je fais on d'ateliers b que dans
la vraie vie et dans la vraie vie bah
j'en fais beaucoup que moi j'en fais
naturellement
quelques-uns sont déjà conquis par le
théâtre est séduit par l'initiative
mais le confinement leur avait permis de
prendre des libertés et des taux au jour
d'hui difficile de revenir à la réalité
je suis prête à revenir parce que basse
et écologique
par contre j'aimerais parolière parce
que cela veut dire hadef l'atelier
d'improvisation permet aux enfants de
s'exprimer mais aussi de s'écouter entre
eux il permet de les canaliser ou de les
libérer en jouant sur les différences de
chacun c'est entrer dans le monde de
chacun et des fois tu dois faire bas
comme ce qui plaît donc l'initiative a
satisfait les organisateurs comme les
enfants notamment avec la nouveauté de
jouer sur le parvis de l'ondh
ils seront de retour dès l'été prochain
les inscriptions se feront du mardi 1er
septembre au samedi 26 septembre 2020